brittany griner writes an open letter to
who
joe biden you guys realize she's been
out there months four months okay so
britney if you're listening to this in
russia and you want to know who to
really write the open letter to write it
to trump he'll probably get you out yup
can you imagine she says i'm terrified i
might be here forever and biden what has
he done what has kamala done i'm sorry
kamala aren't you supposed to be a gamer
here aren't you supposed to get up there
and make a video and say something about
to get her out how is she stuck there
this entire time do you guys remember
when jorge ramos who hates trump
do you remember where jorge ramos was
stuck where was ramos stuck do you guys
remember when ramos had an issue you
guys don't remember this no tyler do you
remember this with ramos you're talking
about universion jorge ramos jorge ramos
where was he is cuba he was he was stuck
i'll tell you right now pull it up right
now exactly what it was sick right he
got sick and then he had so he had
something going on
that he comes out and then trump trump
comes out of nowhere and defends this
guy
so you got a grinder here who is asking
hey that's it
venezuelan government detained him and
him and trump heads all the time oh he
can't stand hey trump hates him who
bails them out trump and guess who he
thinks trump he thanks trump
shout out to him so
griner if you're listening to this i
can't stand the fact that you're stuck
there i can't stand the fact that you're
stuck there the current administration's
campaign was to protect people like
yourself okay
you were the person they were supposed
to protect and go after to make sure
nobody messes with you you're stuck in
russia biden hasn't made one phone call
to say you better release them or else
i'm going to put more funds and
strengthen ukraine there is zero help
going on here okay zero so here's the
thing which the comment you just made
yesterday a guy says to me i post a
comment about uh the the tweet about i
don't know if you saw the tweet i i
tweeted about gas prices
when uh uh
biden's tweet can you go to my twitter
account i'll just read you what i said
when he says uh
yeah when he says so one guy commented i
won't tell you what this guy commented
keep going up keep going up keep going
up uh up up up stone when i respond to
biden's tweet uh keep going keep going
keep going keep going right there okay
click on that one right there
uh you can't do it can you okay all
right anyway so i respond to his tweet
biden says something about in a very uh
demanding voice which by the way i don't
understand why you read write it like
that
in a demanding voice he says
did you pull it up or it's not letting
you okay i'll just read it to you here
but it's okay we don't have to stress
out about it my message to the company
is running gas stations you ready and
setting prices at the pump is simple
this is a time of war and global payroll
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you're
paying for the product and do it now
okay and this is my response my mother
bezos responded first and he gave an
epic message this is the guy he
supported correct and now he's having
virus remorse okay the white house needs
to knock this off so i say i tweet this
out and i say first you blame trump
then covet then putin then oil companies
now gas station owners what's next
blaming car owners for driving too much
then a guy responds back on instagram
and he says the following it's very
important for you to see how the market
is responding to this kind of stuff and
i want to read this guy's comment and
i'll pose my question that i gave to him
he says patrick
we know it's the oil companies raking in
record profit
uh profits and the government collects
their share through taxes and political
contribution they all in on it what say
you patrick bet david i don't know if
you'd speak like that but what say you
patrick david sometimes i talk like that
david here's what i said
why were they not talk taking record
profits under trump
but they are underbide
why not forget politics for a second and
actually answer that question and i got
a few more for you afterwards
if they're taking record profits now
and trump is pro oil
shouldn't they have taken record profits
under trump so where does that argument
go now
so you said wait a minute do you
understand what i'm saying here so hey
if these oil people are getting rich why
do they get rich under a biden
administration not under a trump
administration worldstar post something
the other day about uh about and by the
way world start if you were to guess
which side politically world star's
audience falls is it left middle or
right
libertarian
world star no i would say they're
middlebury
they're left yeah they're 100 left
because a bunch of their videos that
people are left and this guy's a change
no he's joking right now it's left watch
this
go to the instagram post they put when
biden says
uh um
tyler we can hear you type i'm proud to
say that america is officially the first
country in the world
to prove vaccines for six-month-old
babies here's what i want you to do
go read the response of people on that
post you know what you realize
more people agree and are on the same
page than you think
set aside identity politics left right
middle center whatever [ __ ]
95 percent of us all agree
on half the [ __ ] that's not working out
that's the problem today people are
sitting there and saying the hell is
this guy saying i voted for this guy but
what are you talking what are you
putting out there man this is
embarrassing take this thing off don't
don't put that up there but pat you
think they're staying quiet because
they're so loyal and they're not going
to [ __ ] admit that they're messing up
they're not are you sure no no you don't
need everybody to be allowed you only
need 10 of them to not be happy and 10
of them are not staying quiet they're
sick of it they're done with it they're
like this is purely games i'm freaking
sick of it when you mess with someone's
kids and their pockets they get upset
and that's what's happening today so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
you